we heard that there might be a
possibility of a one-on-one interview
with president vladimir zelinsky
and of course we jumped at the chance
going of course to kiev at this moment
gave me the chance to witness personally
what was happening in ukraine i mean it
is right here on our doorstep yeah
there's boxes there's people who've been
standing here we've been told for hours
there are
people with lots of energy bars being
given out people helping but a really
very long queue
and both akadi and i had a very strong
sense walking into the station tonight
that it was the first time we felt we
were in a war
first thing that hits you is the smell
it's the smell of people who haven't
been able to wash
people who are sleeping every night in
the station
and they are people who just they have
those sunken eyes who are really really
tired for the first time now i have felt
okay this is this is real this is the
sense that um
this is the country of war
it was quite a journey to get to see
president zielenski
we first of all drove through kiev past
the anti-tank obstacles
the fortified checkpoints there were a
lot of men with guns we had to change
cars
and eventually we arrived at a big metal
gate
the age who was accompanying us i
remember this very vividly he said
welcome to our fortress
and suddenly there was a slight
kerfuffle but he walks in
let's let's talk about now where we are
now the stage in the war you know is
there a real chance you can win
me
[Music]
foreign
thank you for watching and if you want
to read more of our coverage on russia
and ukraine
please click on the link below
and don't forget to subscribe